In the summer of 1973, pollsters Lou
Harris and George Gallup began asking
people whether President Richard Nixon
should be impeached. At that early point
in the Watergate saga, most people did
not want to impeach the president. Public
opinion turned against Nixon in the late
spring of 1974, and Nixon resigned in
August. Now, Congressman Brad Sherman,
Democrat from California, has filed an
impeachment resolution against Donald
Trump using language that is similar to
the resolutions language used during
Watergate. The measure has only one
co-sponsor, and is unlikely to gain much
traction at this point. What do the polls
say? A July poll from Monmouth University
is pretty much in line with the small
handful of polls we have on the subject.
In it, 41% say President Trump should be
impeached and compelled to leave office,
while 53% say that he should not be. In
our deeply divided political environment,
large majorities of Democrats want to
impeach him; large majorities of
Republicans don't. A third of
independents say he should go.
This is a sensitive issue with serious political ramifications.
Let us know what you think
and let us know your comments. Also, let
us know what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.